about 10 miles outside China's 11th
largest city lies a graveyard
its occupants aren't human nor are they
dead though they have seen better days
these hundreds and hundreds of little
white rectangles are cars electric cars
victims of China's incredibly rapid and
unparalleled Automotive Revolution
when this chongon Ito debuted in 2015
with a range of just over 120 miles and
a top speed of less than 90 miles an
hour it was among the country's
best-selling EVS
at the time China exported only about
000 cars a year less than India or the
United States and a tiny fraction of
Japan or Germany
for the next five years it made only
modest progress
then while the rest of the world was
stuck indoors China leaped ahead of
India followed by the U.S and is on
track to beat both Germany and Japan to
become number one this year
today the Chong gone Edo is but a
forgotten Relic an iPod functional yet
worthless
in its place Chinese drivers have
hundreds of models to choose from
there's the byd Han a Tesla Model S in
Form and Function for nearly half the
price
there's the wooling Bingo an Innovative
hatchback equipped with a built-in
inflatable mattress
there's the best-selling Hong Kwang mini
a five thousand dollar four-seat street
legal micro car
and for those decidedly not on a budget
the seven hundred thousand dollar Rolls
Royce of China the hongchi L5 proudly
used by none other than Xi Jinping
how did China go from 500 EVS on the
streets of Shanghai in 2011 to being the
Undisputed leader in electric cars today
sponsored by ground news the platform
where you can easily compare news
sources protect against media bias and
stay on top of headlines
this is what China's most populous city
look like in April 2000.
you'll notice lots of bikes quite a few
scooters and even some buses
what you don't see a lot of are cars
Just 4 million were on the road for a
population of 1.3 billion a number
surpassed by the United States somewhere
around 1910.
but by 2005 car ownership had more than
tripled and its streets looked like this
suddenly China had an oil problem
the basic challenge can be boiled down
to just two numbers
China consumes upwards of 13 of the
world's oil yet is home to a mere 1.5
percent
the rest it mainly imports from the
Middle East
not only does this make it incredibly
dependent on a small handful of
countries but because the vast majority
of this oil arrives on tankers it also
depends on the generosity of the U.S
Navy to patrol these Waters not to
mention the Goodwill of every nation
along this route
needless to say not ideal
China also had a pollution problem
to this day more of its citizens die of
pollution each year than live in Hawaii
that's well over 4 000 deaths on the
average day
while the country is no stranger to
environmental destruction these costs
are typically born disproportionately by
the less socio-economically advantaged
in other words nickel mines coal plants
and mega dams are built where residents
are powerless to stop them
air pollution by contrast is often worse
in its most populous and Wealthy coastal
cities
according to one estimate 38 of the
Chinese population lives in an area
where the average air quality would be
deemed unhealthy by the EPA
many of 21st century China's largest
protests have revolved around air
pollution
enter electric vehicles
Beijing calculated that nearly a third
of its smog was caused by cars and that
even if all of its electricity were
sourced from coal EVS would still
generate fewer emissions than internal
combustion engines
for years China had been trying to catch
up to German and Japanese automakers by
forcing them to work with local
companies except rather than stealing
from their foreign counterparts as is
often imagined Chinese Engineers became
dependent on them
eventually the Chinese government
realized it simply wasn't going to win
so it decided to start a new race one in
which its competitors had starch was
actually a disadvantage Mercedes and
Toyota and Ford were complacent
unlike traditional cars EVS were
perfectly compatible with China's
economy
where internal combustion engines rely
on small amounts of high skill high-cost
labor EVS rely on relatively larger
amounts of low-skill low-cost labor
by value an electric car is essentially
a battery wrapped in some Packaging
and batteries to grossly oversimplify
are commodities
like any commodity the cost would
inevitably go down with scale
the challenge was sustaining these
companies until they reached
profitability
China's solution was to just buy from
them
after the 2008 financial crisis Chinese
cities helped stimulate the economy by
buying loads and loads of electric buses
and taxis
by 2014 Shenzhen had more than 1200
three years later all 17 000 of its
bosses were Electric
then came the subsidies
billions and billions worth of subsidies
at one point buyers could save as much
as 16 000 US dollars per EV
but although the Chinese government may
have handed out as much as a hundred
billion dollars these subsidies weren't
the biggest reason people bought
electric cars
in a 2016 survey 52 percent of
respondents said they would not have
purchased their EV if not for its
license plates
most Chinese cities distribute new
license plates by Lottery auction or
both
in 2016 the odds of winning the Beijing
lottery or one in 667.
in Shanghai plates can sell for ten
thousand dollars or more
and even with plates you may only be
allowed to drive on certain days of the
week
buy an EV on the other hand and you'll
automatically receive a special green
license plate no lottery or auction
necessary
green plates are China's American
Express Platinum a mass-market golden
ticket to drive on any day of the week
and in some places park for free
unsurprisingly these policies worked a
little too well
the country became saturated with
hundreds of nearly identical brands
it wasn't so much that China was
propping up uncompetitive companies as
hundreds of cities were each propping up
their uncompetitive companies
it was as if Seattle Minneapolis Houston
and Pittsburgh each had its own Tesla
competitor
rather than let the best EV win each
region was too dependent on its local
Champion to allow its failure
on one hand this unusually saturated
Market means Chinese consumers have more
choices than any other country
take a look for instance at EV sales in
America
at first glance this may look like
success
but if we remove the largest company you
can see that EVS haven't really grown
over time Tesla has
Americans effectively have four models
from one major brand to choose from
by contrast Chinese companies released
107 new models last year alone from
Ultra affordable mini EVS to ones where
you can quickly swap out your battery at
one of thousands of stations instead of
waiting for a charge
on the other hand 500 companies is just
too many even for a country as large as
China
so around 2016 the Communist party did
something uncharacteristic it let
capitalism Take the Wheel
subsidies have been slowly phased out
and local governments prohibited from
favoring one company over another
at the same time Beijing dropped a
nuclear bomb on the Chinese Auto
industry
after Decades of carefully nurturing
local companies the Chinese government
rolled out the red carpet for a foreign
competitor
for the first time ever Tesla was given
permission to build its 9 million square
foot Shanghai Factory without working
with a joint Chinese partner
and that's not all
inspired by California Beijing
instituted a credit system
every automaker is now required to sell
a certain number of EVS for each
conventional car it produces
those who fall short must make up the
difference by purchasing credits from
their competitors
since Tesla only produces EVS it earned
nearly 1.6 billion dollars from selling
credits in 2020 alone without this
Revenue the company would have lost 859
million dollars overall that year
one could argue that Tesla was the
largest beneficiary of Chinese State
involvement in the entire industry
protectionism sure for an American
company
[Music]
Chinese companies were suddenly on their
own
meanwhile here was this 800 pound
gorilla with a stronger brand than all
the rest combined to make matters worse
Tesla still on the high end lowered the
cost of its two most popular models by 6
and 13 percent
what happened next was an all-out price
War
in the space of just a few short years
something like 80 percent of China's EV
companies collapsed
Neo one of its largest lost 131 thousand
dollars for every car it sold
but this consolidation painful as it was
had the effect Beijing intended
those that survived have thrived
today about 40 percent of new car sales
in China are electric
of them one Chinese company byd sells
more than the second third fourth fifth
sixth and seventh place Brands combined
it's on track to sell more electric cars
than Volkswagen will sell cars of any
kind this year
Tesla is the only foreign car maker not
in Decline
the days of Ford Honda and BMW
dominating the Chinese markets are over
and the tide is beginning to flow in the
opposite direction
Chinese cars can now be found in Mexico
Saudi Arabia Belgium the UK Chile and
Australia to name just a few
meanwhile at a time when China is
embracing the free market it's now
America's turn to resort to
protectionism
previously nearly every EV buyer in
America could receive a 7 500 tax credit
now only cars whose batteries were
produced in North America and whose
minerals were processed by a U.S Ally
are eligible
America is trying to out China China
to impose the same restrictions it once
criticized Beijing for
but will it work
first consider demand
in a recent survey the average American
said they would need a range of over 500
miles to consider buying an EV the most
of any country
Chinese consumers had the lowest
expectations about half as many
it makes sense China has fast and
efficient high-speed trains for longer
Journeys for Americans car ownership is
a way of life
most Chinese consumers are buying their
first ever car they value its interface
as much as if not more than its
performance
in other words Chinese and American
consumers are different
secondly there's Supply
the Chinese government didn't attempt to
manifest a battery industry out of thin
air it subsidized those that already
existed
byd the country's largest ev brand as
you'll recall began in fact as a battery
maker it successfully produced phone
batteries for years before refocusing on
cars
America doesn't have those companies to
subsidize
it's effectively starting from scratch
finally the most effective Chinese
policies or coercive a civil war would
break out before the United States would
restrict the days of the week on which
you can drive
all of this suggests America has a tough
road ahead
never mind that it's starting this race
about 15 to 20 years too late
as of today just 25 models of cars are
eligible for the new 7 500 federal tax
credit
the other 70 of all electric hydrogen
and hybrid cars sold in America are
ineligible
Biden's inflation reduction Act is an
attempt to have it both ways to increase
the number of EVS on America's roads
while simultaneously decreasing China's
dominance
but the reality is China has spent
decades building up its supply chain
nearly every electric car company in the
world depends on its batteries
it refines over half of the world's
lithium and three-quarters of the
world's nickel and Cobalt
a world without China is at least for
now a world without EVS
nearly 40 percent of EVS in America are
registered in a single state California
and one of the reasons for this
incredible polarization is their media
coverage in choosing what and perhaps
more importantly what not to include
journalists have no choice but to
introduce bias and although we may be
aware of this bias it's often invisible
until compared side by side with other
sources covering the same story
something few of us have the time or
energy to do
enter today's sponsor ground news take
this story about Ford layoffs amid the
EV transition with ground news we can
see that of these 24 sources 20 are left
leaning and 50 right leaning we can also
see how each one is covering the same
story differently revealing its hidden
narrative underneath for example notice
how three out of four left-leaning
Publications mentioned these are
white-collar jobs whereas 8 out of 10
right-leaning Publications omit this
fact entirely we can even click on one
of these sources and see where it gets
its funding ground news makes being an
informed consumer of the news easy with
Android and iOS apps including my
personal favorite widgets for your home
screen and even browser extensions for a
limited time get 30 off your
subscription by clicking the link on
screen or in the description thanks to
ground news for sponsoring this video